isn't it kind of exciting though like
obviously the world has gone completely
into chaos yes it's integrated like we
are in this weird position where the
mainstream media is almost universally
accepted as at least being mostly
foolish or partly full of [ __ ] totally
full of crap
the most the most optimistic person says
well they lie sometimes right that was
never the case with walter cronkite
exactly who also lied all the time or
was it or whatever
he lied all the time and people didn't
realize it they lie like a crack head
hitting on a crack rock alex every word
they say is a lie including and in the
system it's reached new levels of lying
though no no we've reached new levels of
being able to expose them they relied us
into the spanish war in cuba 100 years
ago nothing's changed that's the truth
right rosebud yes yeah yeah gulf of
tonkin operation north always been
livestream
right this is the way they do business
the new york times refused to report
that germany was targeting jews exactly
so because that would be buying into
identity politics at the time because
jews were white and that's what hitler
said jews weren't white and the
government knew about it and they
covered it up including the railroads
which they could have stopped but they
decided not to there's a book called
hold on let me just make one point
there's a book called buried by the
times look it up and this was how they
covered it up because they didn't want
to buy into what hitler was saying
how are we how like how is it now
different you know if they've
i think they've been lying the whole
time yeah but how are we now figuring it
out well i'll tell you what's about to
happen they're devaluing the currency on
purpose to crash all the world of
currencies and bring out the great reset
that's not what we're talking about alex
no this is the build back better agenda
no you're asking malice why it's
happening how to do this no why it's
more obvious when a guy starts talking
you don't talk over them that's how we
do this alex do we have a punch
to pass around let him talk
so you think this go ahead malice tell
us this is this is no it's illiterate
it's the great reset
it's the great reset
reset wars.com
the point is is this the great reset and
they're plunging the world economy on by
design to consolidate control and kill
all the major currencies that's why
there's inflation that's why there's
supply chain breakdowns i'm just telling
you tomorrow's news today there is a
global destruction of the supply chain
and the world currencies to bring in a
new world currency based on the vaccine
passport the issue what they were asking
is you know has it has the corporate
press gotten worse and my point is we
have more mechanisms to expose their
depravity and malfeasance in real time
for example if this had been 20 years
ago they would have been in a position
not to let this call written house video
every anyone would ever see it now if
you have some kind of hacked journalist
with his cameraman one's wearing a mask
one's not everyone's got a phone and all
it takes is one person to film it put on
twitter or facebook and then immediately
everyone can see it in real time michael
i totally agree with you
i just sent you a text message with a
meme it's an amazing meme with alex
you got to look at this it's one of my
favorite memes it's like it's a you are
here meme it's all the [ __ ] that alex
has predicted that's come true
let me read it let me read it can you
get it can you get it on your screen do
you want to do a text message you
[ __ ] primitive wait tweet it tweet it
out post it on post it on instagram you
have a jamie don't have a channel i
can't do that that's already yeah well
they'll pull it up wait wait wait wait i
can facebook it too can i oh yes let me
just say this nicely everybody's right
i i'm obnoxious and i'm horrible and i
apologize no that's not what the name is
michael you're right well thank you sir
i'll send you the meme i've said i know
i'm saying malice is trying to talk
about how the establishment media is
dead i'm talking about how the
establishment's hitting us economically
so he's making a legitimate point i'm
making a separate point about yeah the
the the progenitor of the problems we
have yeah i think you guys are both true
there is a global awakening but there's
also a drastic escalation when it comes
to the great reset the build back better
agenda what clash schwab is having wet
dreams about when it comes to enslaving
humanity making people live in pods
making people eat bugs having them as
little pages
but they're not cousins that's because
they're not going down without a fight
so once the mask is off you better get
whatever but we win the fight or quicker
if we know who they are
make that larger make that meme larger
look at that [ __ ]
pull that out your tv is buying a new
check
elite cabal of sex traffickers check
they're turning the frogs gay
it's from africa that's right yeah uh
bohemian grove czech silver iodide not
what are you sure
uh rich people using baby blood i'm not
that's true no it's happening down in
mexico right now no it is is it really
yes it is people are
doing that yep you are here human monkey
chimeras which he predicted a long time
ago where is that where's that where's
the wait you're saying the elves aren't
real that's not
that's like some [ __ ] that kills
diseases yeah it's true yeah it's
essentially true but also now let me let
me let it makes your skin blue but if
i'll point something out i'll point
something about this meme the tv spying
on you
alex you were pointing these things out
because they were happening the turning
the frogs gave that was atrazine i
believe that's a pesticide right
and that was messing with the endocrine
systems of frogs which was causing weird
deformities i was just covering a
berkeley study yeah but it was more
turning they're changing their gender
and it wasn't making them but here's the
deal i'll be here for five hours joe's
got to go to his show then why are you
yelling
that's how he talked normally you have a
microphone
[Laughter]
joe's nice to say nice things about me
but joe's also predicted a lot of stuff
that came true what did i predict you
product oh my god have you watched your
earlier comedy i don't think oh
probably not maybe
okay i remember in like 1999 i just met
joe before like going to dinner with him
and like this producer i know and then
i'll go to see him at the cap city
comedy club now defunct and he goes up
and he goes let me tell you what's going
to kill the corporate media in hollywood
and everybody it's going to be the
internet it was the first time i heard
say this 100 he goes there's no way they
can people internet this whole freaking
rant and it was all true and then he
went on to say but the sucky part about
technology is is they claim me all these
jetson suits and jet packs and all those
incredible stuff but instead your cell
phone craps out when you're behind a
bush yeah right
the problem like this is like uh you
ever see that movie talladega nights
where he says like he ain't first you
laughs yeah he's like i was high when i
said that same answer you know my
problem there you go man i feel like
corporate media is no longer nbc abc now
it's google and of course i get a
question facebook
as well in a way it's
yes sir there needs to be decentralized
uh open communication where people need
to find out what the [ __ ] is really
going on we're finding that through all
these corporate all these like internet
companies whether it's google or whether
it's facebook or instagram if they can
just censor you based on ideology then
you don't have freedom of speech because
they're the primary means that people
communicate so until we accept that
there's some sort of utility it's not as
simple as it's a private company when
it's literally one of the main two or
three ways that human beings share ideas
across the planet [ __ ] earth it's
bigger than just a company and and i
don't know what the solution to that is
but we have to have that conversation
free the software right right
not having that conversation they're
abusing their power right because the
way it it censors is always in favor of
the left and the people on the left
think that's a good idea but eventually
you can't be left enough it's just going
to keep going it's going to it's a
machine it's pac-man it's just like can
i wait
i got to ask joe um
so a couple years ago you had jack
dorsey on your show
you got a bunch of dislikes on the video
we ended up talking you ended up
inviting me out and i don't know
destroyed it well it's i thought about
that i wanted to ask you like how do you
feel your opinion has changed since
before we did that show and to wear it
today there's a lot of things have
opened my eyes like slowly but surely
like seeing examples of people censored
and some of them that don't make any
sense at all like one of the one of the
best ones was brett weinstein and his
whole um this whole unity party yeah
that yeah when when that got censored i
was like okay
you guys banned an account for no reason
because you thought that that account
which is by a bunch of influential
influential uh intellectuals was going
to somehow another take votes away from
what you thought was the party that
should win and so you just ban the
account so that you're making like these
ideological choices about free speech so
you're saying your free speech is not as
important as the result that i want and
so you're gonna ban people and i when i
saw that i was like this is wild this is
[ __ ] wild and then i talked to a lot
of people that were uh
the second amendment advocates
they were saying before the election
they were going back into their
instagrams and their facebooks and
finding posts from eight nine years ago
and and banning them for those posts
that they were going deep yeah they were
doing that just specifically because
they didn't want people influencing the
vote in any way a thousand here a
hundred there like if they could just
chip away through all these different
angles like this
let's just briefly look at that
imagine it's one thing for an orthodoxy
to take over and make you comply but to
punish you before it took over is
thought crime
before i mean this is mind control this
is this is this is like in science
fiction this was never dreamed of where
you're punished for behavior before the
new orthodoxy comes in so you don't just
submit in the current state you're going
to pay for not
adopting it before it was the new year i
got to correct you this isn't science
fiction this is what they did in the
soviet union where if you were on the
wrong side before stalin took over you
were executed with your family but this
has historical presence
my family was literally tortured in
poland for daring to question the
government or not having the proper
paperwork when during a random passport
check no no no no no no no no i know
that luke i know tyrants do that
listen listen it's retroactive
enforcement yes retroactive they cut his
[ __ ] nose in chinatown
let me let me let me i want to i want to
counter this though because we were
we're actually heading into direction in
this conversation we were talking about
how we're actually starting to realize
how deceptive the media is and then i
pointed it over to drew because these
same tools are what allowed you know
drew to be on the ground exactly
uh during the kenosha internet film it
and then be a witness
the media could have absolutely shut it
down you've heard it you'd see a
newspaper article and it would say white
supremacist crosses state lines with gun
and that's the only thing you'd know and
they tried it drew richie jorge ventura
elijah they broke down you guys were
down there
and then to watch the prosecutor try to
go oh you're a right winger you're evil
it's like it's footage it's raw like joe
said
oh and then they saw the raw footage
once you see that it's
that my footage game
slanted in a certain way and i responded
and i said well
yes it's blm and antifa literally
rioting in the footage what people need
to understand is this propaganda is so
dangerous not because they're just
telling lies but they're attempting to
control the narrative which is an
attempt to control your mind and that's
what's dangerous whether you're
republican or a democrat that should
seriously concern you because this is
what they do to control the minds of
millions of people and it's allowed on a
daily basis and it's like why don't it's
encouraging why don't people take issue
with this that people are trying to
control your mind because on a daily
basis the average man would rather be uh
safe than be free we're taught since
kids to defer that expert
and one of the reasons
one of the reasons they always talk
about follow the experts it's not just
with uh um kovid it's also with this am
i going to look at the footage and draw
my own conclusion or am i going to
listen to the prosecutor okay joe you
were saying i'm so sad because i don't
know any progressive i know a lot of
progressives and not one of them knows
that one of the
victims of kyle was a pedophile they all
think it was an innocent black blm
protagonist who raped a kid it's not
like he had a child attraction five kids
five kids and he was an underage boy
during this
you know battle with him
so it's it messes with people so badly i
know so many people that have no
information about the case but have an
opinion completely made up wasn't the
other guy didn't he get all his charges
dismissed on previous six days before
six days before he had a dui charge
dropped but he was a career criminal i
mean he went down for domestic abuse
prowling trespassing two duis felony
burglary two counts of carrying a
firearm while intoxicated this is a hulk
this information is not based on reality
this is a left-wing cult and they're
they're pumping stuff out and then
they're confirming this belief they're
they're all getting together and they're
ignoring contrary evidence yes they're
ignoring any narrative that challenges
their belief about what happened and
they're not looking at it realistically
they're only looking at it like you
would look at it if you're in a [ __ ]
cult sounds like a weird left well cult
is a religion that's just like it's just
older now
well the cult doesn't let you ask
questions joe go ahead well a cult is
made by a guy and that guy knows it's a
cult and a religion that guy's dead
that's the difference like religions are
just cults that last longer you know
some of them prove to be worthwhile put
like social and economic and and even uh
moral structures like they actually
benefit society like some some cults
they're based on rituals or things that
people learn and they realize this is a
better way to live their life and but
some of them are just based on the
present moment of gathering the most
amount of whether it is uh influence or
finances or
what what power whatever the [ __ ] it is
that's what this is yo what i totally
agree so let me ask the next question
i really want to hear what you ever say
what is the period we're in now because
it seems like it's coming to an end this
is kali yuga man this is this is some
weird [ __ ] that was predicted by the
bhagavad gita this is this like this
battle of the gods ragnarok tell me this
is what happens in cultures like they go
through these like these pitches these
ups and downs and it's almost inevitable
like it's almost impossible for us with
our human wart reward systems that are
based on like animal emotions and
biology to man to manage
millions and millions and millions of
people all on one continent with money
and the economy and the [ __ ]
environment it's almost impossible to do
so it almost always slides into
authoritarianism and the best way it
slides into authoritarianism is to
control the narrative
you gotta leave keep going brother
so you say it's almost impossible how
would you say we can do it
we gotta love mushrooms other we need
mushrooms we gotta realize we're all in
this thing together we can instead of
competing with each other just do your
best and give everybody hugs i don't
know i agree so let's expand on that now
you don't agree you're out of this thing
why do hallucinogens take and properly
create such peace why are they because
they eliminate the ego and the ego is
responsible for most of the conflict
most of the conflict is instead of
thinking i gotta get this guy back just
relax everybody relax everybody like
look at this like what does everybody
want in terms like you forgave me three
years ago when i was being a daddy buddy
and it was so much better forgive
everybody listen it was amazing what
does everybody want this life you want
good friends you want to be safe you
want your your children to go to good
schools you want your loved ones to be
protected you want people to get by and
have a good life for as long as they
possibly can that's what everybody wants
but you know that other people are
trying to stop you from having that
other people stop you from having that
there's a few sociopaths that want to
gather it all up for themselves i
forgive you amounts of people but but
joe i i've had this conversation with
ian a whole lot because ian's the voice
on our show who's always telling us to
stop being so dark and try and bring
people together but you look at the
prosecutor in in the written house case
he's a demon over overwhelmed like lying
yeah you see the judge say that destroy
child's life grave constitutional
violation i think that's been going on
forever it has finally we have the
internet correct thank you yeah and now
now we can see it for whatever and now
we can see it and now conservatives are
realizing you know the local
conservative line about like oh if you
haven't done anything wrong don't worry
about getting arrested you'll be fine
i know but conservative is now realizing
wait a minute when the government the
eye of sauron has you in your in their
sights they're going to do whatever they
can i've been experiencing that where
like they just lie about what were you
just saying about not interrupting ah
miles
i was just just the one point is people
have a lot of malice for me i don't have
a lot of love for you
start over i'm not gonna start over i'm
just gonna say my one sentence which is
conservatives now realizing when the
government which is the eye of sauron
has it you in their sights they're going
to do whatever they can to break you and
this is something that
disproportionately hurts poor people and
the left has been arguing about that for
a long time and they were right yeah
yeah that's inarguable right yes
but now the left side
free speech
well there's something to say about
what's happening right now some people
have called it the fourth turning you
could feel it it's it's energetic you
know something's happening you see the
titanic you see the iceberg you're like
holy cow the ship is heading somewhere
but at the end of the day we could still
decide where it goes and i think to
joe's point mushrooms decentralization
are ways to start the conversation but i
think we should focus on that as well
because i think that's the true kind of
opening that we should be really
examining and looking into because there
is something to talk about with so much
power and influence here we could do
something incredible here i don't know
about mushrooms but that nad stuff was
legit thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you